hey this is presh tallwalker
calculate the minimum value
of the square root of the quantity x
minus 4 squared plus the quantity y
minus 10 squared plus the square root of
the quantity x minus 44 squared plus the
quantity y minus 19 squared
this is for real numbers x and y
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
one way to understand the question
is to plot the graph z is equal to the
sum of the square roots
the shape resembles a paraboloid
and its minimum value happens when z is
equal to 41.
thus intuitively we know the answer is
equal to 41.
but this approach doesn't give us any
understanding of the structure of the
question
to do that
let's make a plot in x y space
let a be the point 410
and b be the point 4419
let c be the point x y
construct ac
we can then construct a right triangle
where one leg is the distance between x
and 4 and the other leg is the distance
between y and 10.
the hypotenuse is the length of ac
and this is equal to the square root of
the sum of the squares of the legs
thus
the first square root exactly
corresponds to the length of ac
we can then construct cb
and we will have a similar phenomenon
where the second square root is exactly
the length of bc
thus the sum of the square roots is
exactly equal to the length of ac plus
the length of bc
we now want to minimize the sum of these
distances
we've transformed an algebra question
into a geometry question
let's now construct a b
by the triangle inequality the length of
ac plus the length of bc
is greater than or equal to the length
of a b
and equality holds exactly when c is
along the line segment a b
this will be the minimum sum
so we just need to calculate the length
of a b
this will be equal
to the square root of the quantity 44
minus 4 squared plus the quantity 19
minus 10 squared
this simplifies to be the square root of
4 d squared plus 9 squared which is
equal to forty-one
and that's the answer
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions or we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time